- Good afternoon, everyone.
Thank you so much for
coming out this afternoon.
And so welcome, all of you, to
the Chubb Fellowship lecture
a very distinguished guest,
Dr. Hawa Abdi Dhiblawe.
As Somalia's most-- (applauding)
Somalia's most celebrated
and known physician,
humanitarian and human rights activist.
And we're also extremely
delighted to have Dr. Abdi
and her daughter, Dr. Deqo Mohamed.
(applauding)
A similarly important physician
and human rights activist.
We're really thrilled to
have both of them back,
well, for Deqo, back at Yale with us,
and for Dr. Abdi, of course,
the first time to Yale.
This is truly an honor.
So I wanna begin by first
asking everyone to please
turn off their cellphones
or any kinds of devices
that you might have, just
so that we don't disrupt
the conversation today.
And we also ask that if
you are taking photographs,
to probably refrain from doing
so, especially with the flash
because it's very bright in here,
and it's already quite distracting.
So that would be very, very helpful.
So I should pause and introduce myself.
I'm Mary Lui, I'm the head
of Timothy Dwight College.
I'm a professor in the
Department of History,
in the program in American Studies.
As the head of Timothy Dwight College,
I have the honor of serving as custodian
of the illustrious Chubb Fellowship.
Established in 1941 out
of a prior large donation
for education purposes.
Made in 1936 by Hendon
Chubb, who graduated
from the class of 1895.
Since establishment, the
Chubb Fund has adhered
to the goals of providing encouragement
and aid to Yale students
interested in government
and American public affairs.
And I'm pleased to announce this year
that we took some of the
Chubb Fellowship money
and created summer
fellowships for TD students
to engage in the world of public service.
And it's really thrilling.
We've awarded six Chubb
fellowships this year,
and it's extremely exciting to see
what these students will do.
The fellowship initially
aimed to foster among Yale
undergraduates an
interest in public service
and local and state affairs.
It grew over the years to include numerous
distinguished visitors in
national and international affairs
as well as leaders in the
world of arts and humanities.
Since the 1940's, the Chubb
Fellows lecture series
has inspired generations of
Yale students to undertake
public service and pursue leadership roles
in the hopes of using their Yale education
to create a better world
today and for posterity.
The fellowship has hosted
four US presidents,
George HW Bush, Gerald Ford,
Jimmy Carter, and Harry Truman.
And in recent years, we
have welcomed a wide range
of national and international leaders,
including Wynton Marsalis,
Aung San Suu Kyi,
and Shah Rukh Khan.
It's a great honor for
Timothy Dwight College
to offer this public lectureship series
as a gift to the Yale University community
as well as the greater
New Haven community.
So welcome to all of
you to today's events.
So with this quick
description of the history
and aims of the fellowship, I'm delighted
that we're welcoming to
Yale today Dr. Hawa Abdi.
We're most grateful to her and her family
for working with us since
early January to join us
in New Haven, and to be
honest, when we began
the conversations, we
did not expect for this
spring semester's Chubb Fellowship lecture
that we would be navigating
such a complicated
and difficult legal and political terrain
to bring Dr. Abdi into the United States.
But we're extremely thankful
that she is here with us today.
And I want to take a moment
to acknowledge the many people
on this campus, that is, here
on this campus and beyond,
who were very steadfast
in their assistance
in bringing Dr. Abdi here.
First and foremost, I
wish to particularly thank
President Peter Salovey, and
his office, for giving support.
Yale University's Office
of the General Counsel,
particularly Alex Dreier, vice
president and general counsel,
and his wonderful staff of attorneys,
Kara Haas, Caroline
Hendel, and Susan Sawyer,
and I just want the three of
them to pop up for a second
and just be acknowledged
for all their amazing work.
(applauding)
I think I owe you all some flowers.
I wish to thank my colleagues
also in the Yale Law School,
particularly Professor
Muneer Ahmad, for his advice
and support, and last but
not least, I wish to thank
Assistant Dean Sara
Lulo, who's right there.
(applauding)
Who directs the law school's
international programs
and Gruber Program for Global
Justice and Women's Rights.
Dean Lulo's ongoing support
throughout the spring
has been instrumental in today's events,
and I cannot thank her enough
for everything she's done.
So I will pause here and
introduce two wonderful people,
an alum and a current
student, to introduce our
distinguished guests for this afternoon.
Introducing Dr. Abdi
and Dr. Mohamed will be
Nicola Suku, who graduated from Yale,
and Timothy Dwight College, in 2016,
and senior Charlotte Finegold.
I've asked these amazing
students to do the honor
or introducing our distinguished guests,
because it was Nicola's first efforts
that brought the incredible
work of Doctors Abdi and Mohamed
to my attention, and I
can't thank her enough
for reaching out and telling
me about their amazing work.
So Nicola's originally from
Cape Town, South Africa,
and majored in Ethics,
Politics, and Economics
and participated in the
multidisciplinary academic program
in education studies; as
a senior, she co-directed
the project to design human
rights conflict resolution
curriculum for the Dr.
Hawa Abdi Foundation.
After graduating, she
moved back to South Africa
to work at Equal Education,
a youth-led social movement
that uses research,
litigation, and activism
to fight systemic inequalities
in the South African
education system.
So we're thrilled to have
her back from South Africa,
to be here with us today.
And Charlotte is from California,
and a member of the first
class of the multidisciplinary
program in human rights
connected to the Yale Law School.
She now directs a team of undergraduates,
who are designing the
Hope Village Human Rights
and Conflict Resolution Curriculum
for the Dr. Hawa Abdi Foundation.
Please join me in welcoming Nicola
and Charlotte to the podium.
(applauding)
- Thank you, Professor Liu.
We are very grateful to you
and the Chubb Fellowship
for giving us the
opportunity to introduce two
of our personal heroes, Dr. Hawa Abdi
and her daughter, Dr. Deqo Mohamed,
for this very prestigious event.
- Okay, Dr. Abdi was born
in Mogadishu, Somalia.
She studied medicine on a
Soviet Union scholarship,
and became one of her
country's first gynecologists.
While practicing as a doctor,
Dr. Abdi also obtained
her law degree.
Later, she noticed the need
for a rural women's clinic
and established one of
those on her family's land,
close to Mogadishu.
For years, she woke up very
early to tend to her farm,
and then traveled to
Mogadishu, where she worked
full time as a doctor and
professor of medicine.
And then afterwards, in
the evenings, returned home
to see to the line of women
waiting outside her clinic,
on her land.
These women paid only
if they had the means,
and Dr. Abdi invested all that she had
into maintaining and growing
the clinic to meet the need.
But following the outbreak
of civil war in Somalia
in 1991, the need became overwhelming.
As those fleeing the
violence of Mogadishu by foot
arrived at the clinic en masse,
Dr. Abdi opened up her land
to provide them with medical aid, food,
clean water, and shelter.
She stretched her limited
resources as far as she could,
in an attempt to save the
lives of the hundreds of people
who arrived at the camp, daily.
But in the first year of the
war, Dr. Abdi and her team
were forced to bury
more than 10,000 people.
Nevertheless, she persevered.
Renamed the Hawa Abdi Hope Village,
the site is now home
to over 90,000 people,
who live peacefully together.
They have access to a 400-bed hospital,
a sustainable agricultural program,
a women's education center,
and primary and high schools.
Dr. Abdi's 2013 memoir,
Keeping Hope Alive,
co-written with Sarah Robbins,
who has joined us here
today, details a life
of remarkable strength.
Even as the violence of
war, famine, and poverty
took the lives of so many,
including some of those
most dearest to her.
Dr. Abdi's resilience
and the resilience of all
she has built, is evident still today.
In Somalia, where there's
yet another terrible drought,
her village is mobilizing to
feed and care for its people.
Dr. Abdi has been recognized
in the US an abroad
for her decades of
incredible humanitarian work.
She is a Nobel Peace Prize nominee,
and has received the
John J. Justice Award,
the Vital Voices Woman of the Year Award,
BET's Social Humanitarian Award,
and the Roosevelt Institute's
Freedom From Want Award.
And it is fitting that
she should be honored
with a Chubb Fellowship today.
- Dr. Deqo Mohamed and her
sister, Dr. Amina Mohamed,
have always shared their
mother's vision for Hope Village
and have assisted in the hospital
since they were teenagers.
Dr. Deqo Mohamed studied
medicine in Moscow.
She then came to the US as a refugee,
where she gained extensive
experience in health care,
before returning to Somalia.
She now runs Hope Village and is CEO
of the Dr. Hawa Abdi Foundation.
She also advises the
Somalian Ministry of Health
on women's and girls' rights.
Her sister now lives in Kenya,
where she runs her own
women's health clinic.
The partnership between Yale
and the Dr. Hawa Abdi Foundation
began several years ago,
and strengthened last fall
when Dr. Deqo Mohamed was here
as a Greenberg World
Fellow, and teamed up with
Gabriella Hernandez
Cardoso, another member
of the World Fellows class of 2016,
and Professor James Levinson
of the Jackson Institute
for Global Affairs, to
design a course in which
Yale students would create a
business plan for Hope Village.
This spring, graduate and
undergraduate students
from across Yale are helping
Hope Village residents
to identify products
that they can manufacture
and sell both inside and
outside of Hope Village,
so as to make the
community more sustainable.
And Nicola and I are endlessly thankful
to have been entrusted
with another project that,
had Liu mentioned, that Dr.
Deqo Mohamed commissioned
from Yale: a human rights and
conflict resolution curriculum
for Hope Village's new high school.
Since October, 2015, when
our team began working
on this task, we have
had guidance and support
from Dr. Deqo Mohamed and
her teachers on the ground,
as well as from Hope
Metcalf and Jim Silke,
the directors of the Schell
Center for International
Human Rights, and Sarah Luloe.
Our four-year curriculum,
rooted in the history
and values of Hope
Village, will get students
to think critically about
the history of conflict
in Somalia, about what human rights are
and how they can use them
to advocate for change
in their community, and we are so proud
of the hard work put in by our
team, who is also here today.
- We feel incredibly lucky
to have Dr. Hawa Abdi
with us today, to share
lessons from a lifetime
dedicated to the selfless
service of her people.
We have a great deal to
learn from the community
that Dr. Abdi has built.
One that continues to
prioritize gender equality
and solidarity across ethnic lines,
even in times of unimaginable hardship.
- And before Dr. Abdi
and Dr. Mohamed speak,
their work will be introduced
through the following video,
produced in 2013 by the Vital
Voices Global Partnership,
which works with women
leaders to further women's
economic empowerment,
political participation,
and human rights.
- [Dr. Abdi] My mother was dreaming
that I would be a great person.
She became pregnant with her seventh child
when I was 11 years old.
As her stomach swelled,
she felt weakness and pain.
But she said: no problem, Hawa.
Everything will be okay.
Whether it comes to us
through violence, disease,
or even childbirth, death
is not the end of our story.
You have to get up and
help someone who needs you.
I became a doctor because
I wanted to save others
from feeling the pain I
felt when my mother died.
The Somalia I grew up in was
so much different than today.
Mogadishu was the best
place in all Africa.
In the rural areas,
children had fresh milk,
fresh meat, fresh air.
Life was very beautiful, very
simple, and very peaceful.
It started to go bad in 1988,
when the government collapsed.
More and more people come to
us to escape the fighting.
The Somali people have a
tradition of hospitality.
When a traveler comes to you,
you have to give him the
best of what you have.
It seems only natural that
the problems we could solve,
like giving someone a place to stay
and a feeling of safety, should be solved.
When space became full,
families began to sleep under the trees.
After more than 20 years,
it became 90,000 people.
These people have become my family.
Here, we are all Somali.
If you want to identify with
your clan, you cannot stay.
In time, my children become doctors,
and now we work together.
Each crisis we face gives way to the next,
as a new group takes control of our area.
Sometimes, these children with their guns,
they told me: you are an old woman.
You cannot be in charge.
I said: and you are a strong young man.
What have you done for these people?
Whether through fighting or famine,
we have lost as many as 50 people per day.
But we get up, we go on.
And we help someone who needs us.
Today, our one-room clinic
is a 400-bed hospital.
I live for the hope that peace will come.
That my children and my grandchildren
will someday know the Somalia I loved.
Until that time, they can
build on what I have started.
I am Dr. Hawa Abdi.
This is my vital voice.
Now, raise yours.
(somber music)
(applauding)
- Please join us in
welcoming Dr. Hawa Abdi
and Dr. Deqo Mohamed, once again.
(applauding)
- So, thank you so much for coming here.
As I said, this is a true honor
to have you here on Yale's campus,
and to talk to this wonderful audience,
who's here to learn about your work.
With Hawa Abdi Village and
your long career of service
to Somalia.
I just wanted to start
by asking you a question
about what you remember,
growing up in the Somalia
that had undergone so many changes,
from independence onward, and
how you came to the decision
to become a doctor, to serve your people?
(murmuring)
- When I was a child and died my mother,
I felt bad, and I decided at
that time to become a doctor.
To save mothers' lives.
My father was kind and he was intelligent.
All his friends come at that time.
To send a girl outside was very difficult.
For Somali, the traditional way.
But he send me, because he could,
and he was understanding that studying
is the very best things of life.
He sent me to Soviet Union,
and when my dream became,
when my dream became over,
I decided to study well.
When I went into the Soviet Union,
I was studying at night and
day and became a doctor.
To save other mothers.
So, I finished my study after seven years.
I come back, I began
to work the hospitals,
because with troubles in Mogadishu,
I have seen that the
justice is not very good.
Then I began to study the faculty of law.
In 1972, I finished in
1971, medical school.
Then I finished also the law school.
I was working in big hospitals,
but always they would brought
in us a mother who was
already nearly to die, because
she lost a lot of blood.
Or the child is not family, the
delivery was very difficult.
In rural areas, they were
bringing us many mothers
who were dying before we had done nothing.
So I decided to go to the rural area
to help women in rural areas.
- So how long were you
working in Mogadishu,
before you decided to open the clinic?
- I finish in '71, and I went
out to the rural area in 1983.
- And did you continue your
relationship to the hospitals
in Mogadishu, or did you
completely just build a brand new--
- No, I was having Mogadishu's
hospitals with my friend,
who was there working, and
we were, they were coming
Sundays, we have Fridays, and
on Fridays they were coming
to me, because the city sometimes,
they want to go outside,
breathe the fresh air.
We were having a relation
with the big hospitals
in Mogadishu,
but at 1990, it broke out civil war.
This civil war was
caused because in Africa,
all we have this which
is called: tribalism.
Tribalism, two clans
were becoming to fight.
One clan would be stronger
than the other, one weak.
They will kill and
destroy all the property.
- Can you say a little bit
about what your clinic was like
before the civil war broke out in 1991?
- I began a one-room clinic.
- A one-room clinic.
- But those, the rural areas,
sometimes they don't want
to go to the hospitals.
They prefer their traditional medicine.
So to convince them was very difficult.
But at last they understood
that the hospital can help them.
So they come to me.
Many patients, maybe hundreds about.
Numbers, my numbers was hundred per day.
- At the peak was 100 per day?
- Yes, yes, yes.
- But at first, did you
have difficulty getting, ah,
getting local people
to come to the clinic?
Is that what you were saying?
- 10 or 20 before.
In the first few days.
- The first few days, yes.
- Then we began to, with my daughter Deqo,
going to the small, small
villages, every Friday.
And to us, if there is a child sick,
or a woman sick, or a, we
have plenty of malaria.
We were bringing our medicine.
I was checking when I
would go, in a white coat,
the children first, then
they were running from us.
Then, they adopted us because the child,
when the child is sick, Deqo
was distributing medicine.
I visited, we have our medicine,
I write a prescription,
Deqo will bring and will
distribute, or to give the child,
which is sick, or the women.
- And how old was Deqo at the time?
When she was traveling with
you in the rural areas?
- I was 10 or 12, I think, so very young.
- Yes, yes, she was very, very small.
- I think what she meant,
because of Somali culture
and tradition, hospital
is seen as a death place.
So, because they are
arriving, the patient comes
to the hospital, last minute, and were,
we don't have a well-equipped hospital,
so we're losing a lot of patients.
So they see it's a disaster place to go.
So when in the beginning
they didn't come to her,
she came up with this mobile clinic,
where we go out and go
to them in the villages.
So it was very fun, just
to be around and traveling.
And as a kid, we were just having fun.
So I learned all the medicine,
antibiotics, parasetamol,
the various names, and
they were just like,
give 10, 15, so we were being heard from.
I was a pharmacist earlier
than I become a doctor.
(laughing)
- Did you incorporate
traditional methods of healing,
as part of your practice?
(speaking foreign language)
- Sometimes.
Sometimes I was doing.
Sometimes more effective,
traditional medicine,
than other modern medicine.
Especially in Africa.
- So I imagine this must have
been a very peaceful time
of practicing before the war.
- Yes, yes, very peaceful time.
- And so can you describe how it changed
after the outbreak of the civil war?
How did that affect your clinic.
- Oh, it was a disaster.
There was no one would go to his job.
Africa, we live with what we
have: the farms and animals.
Especially women of
Africa are very strong.
They were carrying their
family with their hands,
because they are digging
farmers, leading animals,
and they are carrying their
children on their back.
So, we had a difficult time
after broke out civil war.
Because no one can go and do his job.
- Do you still remember the first families
that came to your clinic for assistance?
- People coming, continuing to come to me.
All my friends.
(speaking foreign language)
It was 1,500 families, first.
- 1,500 families?
In the first week, or?
- In the first months.
- First months, I see.
And then I know from
reading the autobiography
that they just kept coming.
- Yeah, they were coming
then after, bit by bit,
until they reached 15,000 families.
- At what point was it that
it reached 15,000 families?
After how many months?
- Two years.
- Two years?
- Years, we have to peak in 2008,
when the war is exacerbated
and all three million
of Mogadishu residents just had to flee
in a couple of days, because
of a severe clash happened
between the government and Al-Shabaab,
and Ethiopian was invading at that time.
It was Islamic corps, so
it was a political mess.
So the city became a battle zone,
so three million people had to flee.
And in our hospital,
it's right on the road
where you leave the city;
we're only 20 kilometers away
from Mogadishu, so that's where we were.
We just took as much as we could,
and when it reached up to 90,000,
we didn't have any space to
have them, so we just had to--
- And it's an impossibility to feed them.
Or to give water.
So I began to appeal to
international organizations,
like ISTRC, like WFP, UNICEF and AMICEF.
They come to me
immediately, giving me food.
(unintelligible muttering)
And they're giving me fuel,
because we had a well, but to
bring water, it takes fuel.
They were giving me fuel, food, shelter.
They were giving borscht, medicine,
they're giving us medicine.
- I imagine when it first began,
you had no idea how
long it would go on for.
And of course, it went on for decades.
I'm curious, at what point did you realize
this wasn't just going to
be a temporary shelter,
or relief center?
- There were international organizations,
they were giving us plastic shelters.
(speaking foreign language)
I was always thinking
that maybe one week after
would come the peace, but
peace went far, far, far.
Until now, for 27 years.
- Yeah, so what, can you describe what,
clearly you went through
many, many hardships
in dealing with the magnitude.
- It was bad, it was
seeing very bad things,
you know, without, with
bothering poor people,
and treating bad, but
you cannot do nothing.
You are only one person, a woman.
In Africa.
It was very difficult.
I have witness of many bad things.
- You created a state within
the state for that 25 years.
- These people are
fighting because of clan.
In Africa, we have tribalism,
which is worse than terrorism.
- Tribalism is worse than terrorism?
- Tribalism is way worse than terrorists.
Because terrorism, if you
get the law and power,
you can eradicate it.
But tribalism, two clans will fight,
some will be beaten, but
those clan was beaten,
they will tell all their children,
and those children will
tell other, other children.
So it's never finished.
- Generation to generation.
- Generations.
- So that's why you studied
the law, I think so.
- Then, family, strong
family and weak families,
they will fight, the
strong family will come
and beat those weak families,
which is my village.
So, I thought: how to
live with these people?
How to command?
I said, ah, but we with internal rule,
I don't know, no clan division in Somalia.
If you come to my village,
you are Somali only.
If you are strong, it's up to you.
You go, you are a clan.
If you come to me, I will
give you space to live,
clean water, healthy water, free.
If you are begin to say
that: I'm that clan,
I will beat this weak clan.
You will go out.
So, the people in my
village became equal then.
They did not fight another time.
There was no powerful clan who
was pretending to be higher
over other families.
They became equal.
- So you were able to
create the equal society,
not allowing for clan divisions,
but instead being Somali?
- Yes, yes.
- So I'm sure that was
not an easy process.
Were there people who
still refused not to have
their clan allegiances, but, yeah,
how did you deal with that?
- Then, after a few months,
it begins a family violence.
The men becoming to beat their wives,
because men was working the day,
and coming when (muttering),
and he saw all his friends.
Now they are standing in
under the plastic shed,
plastic, plastic--
- Sheets.
- Sheet.
My father, mother and children.
And when they took, he
began to beat his wife.
But family violence came up, up, up.
Children are running, because
they love their mother
and their father, but
father is beating mother.
They are running to me: Mama Hawa,
our father is beating our mother.
And I've sent some people.
We had others, it lead
us to do some decision.
You cannot beat, but you
have, I said: bring him.
And with the jail.
- And put him in jail?
- Yes, and they did.
We are (unintelligible).
We would open some, these youth people,
would bring him and put in the jail.
- And you should describe
what this jail was,
because I'm not sure everyone knows.
(laughing)
(muttering)
- It was only store.
- Storage?
- Storage, yes.
- A storage closet.
- Yes, a storage closet.
They would sit down there,
and after a few days,
we are not talking with
them, until the elders
and women, or the youth committee,
will decide this case, he will stay there.
- So you basically created rule of law.
Or the, ah--
- But there's just two rules.
Two simple rules to stay with me.
First, it's Somali in my village.
They become equal, without any pretending
that he come from a strong clan.
- So everyone's equal, no
one's pretending to be,
or claiming to be from a
stronger or better clan?
- Yeah, yes.
- And the second rule?
- The second rule, the
men stop beating his wife.
- There would be no
domestic violence, yeah.
(applauding)
- And it's, I've heard
it's very effective,
being in the storage closet.
(laughing)
- It is effective, if
you're in a dark small room
with a bunch of food sacks around you,
and you get claustrophobia
in that little thing.
But it works, most of it,
the majority of the time.
But it took, I think,
with my mom's persistence,
and 25 years of living there.
So in the beginning, the
people left, some of them,
it was some clashes, but finally,
by the time I arrived in 2007,
the rule was in place,
so they were teaching me.
Some of them forgot I was
there in the beginning,
when the rule was implemented.
It's like: make sure if there
is any domestic violence,
you immediately arrest the husband.
And it's like: okay, I will do it.
(laughing)
So the committee was telling
me one day when I was there:
that's the rule, your mom did it.
So my mom basically
acts as a supreme court.
- She's the supreme court?
(laughing)
- The committee decides how
things should go, the youth,
the young generation
who grew up in the camp,
are doing the police action, you know,
arresting and all that,
but my mom is the final,
if they cannot decide,
she's the supreme court,
where we should appeal if we
could not decide the cases.
So finally, my, all my friends and I,
we used to have our fun and say:
mom, you never get to practice your law.
So this is the opportunity. (laughing)
You practice your law, after the war.
- It's held with me.
And also, it's helped with
the society of my village.
- That's great.
What about maintaining structure and order
in terms of food distribution
and resources and water,
when all of that is in such short supply?
It must be very challenging to be as fair
as you possibly can with
all the needy families.
- We decided we'd divide
in the village, six parts.
Every part they were
having their committee
who will bring his part his food, water,
and also cleaning the village.
Sanitation of the village.
They are responsible, this committee.
- And I think the majority
would make more beautiful
the structure, and the
system is people find a life.
Because the majority of the camp is IDP's,
internally displaced
people, and in Somalia,
they're just sitting and awaiting aid,
or there's a clash that's happening.
So within our village, they have a life.
They wake up in the
morning, the elderly gather,
and they decide what is the problem next,
how we could solve.
The young generation cleans up, you know,
acts as the police, so you could feel,
you know, become more alive.
So you don't have to keep telling them,
it's part of their daily routine,
and they take very proudly.
They say: oh, we are Hawa Abdi Village,
we have this, this is our rules.
They tell everyone who comes to it.
So it's, it was fascinating me being away,
after 10 years and coming back,
and seeing the transformation.
- So, one of the most well-known incidents
that made international
headlines was in 2010,
when Hizbul Islam basically
tried to take over the camp,
and my understanding is
you were put under arrest.
They were trying to force you
to relinquish full control.
That was mentioned in the video, yes.
- 2010, it made.
The come, a group of
Islamist, Hizbul Islam,
they come and they say:
you are woman and old.
You cannot run this
camp with these people.
You are over, you have
to hand over and give us.
We will command; we are
young and we are men.
Okay, I say, you are men
because you have two testes.
But the goats also-- (laughing)
- It's okay, you're both doctors.
(laughing)
- You have two testes, but
the goat also has two testes.
What you have done to serve your society?
The people was with me, they come,
say: you keep quiet, they may kill you.
No, I say, I will tell what's the truth.
What they have done for their society,
but they are coming to tell
me to hand over this camp,
or this village?
You are a woman and old.
You cannot run this job.
You are not in a position
to run this village.
I said: I am sorry, but
you have not done nothing
for this society.
If you are men, it's up to you.
- Were you not scared at
all, during this whole time?
Because they had weapons, if I understand,
very scary weapons.
- Yes, yes. (laughing)
One of my friends, he says
like: Hawa, keep quiet!
Not say nothing like that.
(speaking foreign language)
- Yeah, so, but they come and attacked.
- And after a few days,
they surrounded us,
and they send all the
weapons with heavy shelling
in the hospital, in my camp, in my house.
In the pediatrician
ward and maternity ward,
they send us, and at that
time, there was water
in the area, and many
children were admitted
in that pediatric ward with
fluid, water in the brain.
- The hospital was working fully.
- Yes, and there was a
woman, where we operated,
I operated, C-section, took the child,
they're lying on their beds,
but after heavy shelling, they run.
And some, one of those
women opened up four stitch.
- But luckily, the patient didn't die.
One of our security guards passed away,
and was killed during the attack.
- And they come and
say, during the attack,
my daughter is connecting with BBC Somali,
Somali language broadcast.
And I tell that Hizbul Islam attacked me,
and my people now, they are,
they want to destroy our
hospital and my people.
I don't know how many will remain.
I made here, (vocalizing), a big noise.
And all the Somali here, they come,
they come after and
they: you talk outside.
Give your mobile.
With me were five of my nurses.
They took all of our mobiles.
They brought the minibus,
and they say: stand up.
Me, first.
Okay, I stood up.
The other children, the
other nurse also stand up.
Come.
I went after them, we all went after them.
They put us in a minibus.
All the people were crying.
They thought that they would kill us,
but they did not kill us.
They brought us somewhere
where they have their offices.
And they closed one room.
- They basically arrested you
and have you there in 10 hours.
- Yes, in 10 hours we were there.
- Under house arrest?
- Yeah, no.
- Yeah, before the house
arrest, they took her
to their place, and after
she live-broadcasted.
(overlapping interjections)
- They bring me my phone.
They say: you have many supporters.
Tell your people that we don't harmed you,
that you are safe, you are healthy.
I talked first to my daughters.
And I say: I'm alive, I'm okay.
I have no problem.
- And it was the longest 10
hours of my life, I think.
So, we didn't know where she is,
for her persistence in being strong,
but still, we were all blaming
her in somehow, you know?
She shouldn't say: resist them.
But we're lucky to have her back.
The live broadcast, I think,
made them more aggressive
and made them more mad,
because the all-over Somalia
was listening to their
shelling, on the radio.
So the whole country was shocked.
Like, how in the world
you can attack a hospital?
Especially Mama Hawa?
So everyone was calling
them and then they get
very scared and they give her the phone
and they say: you need
to talk to your people.
You're still alive, we didn't kill you.
Just tell them so they get off
of our shoulders, you know?
They're pushing us,
making sure you're alive.
And she talked to them, she talked to us,
and we told all our community--
- All our friends, also.
- You're alive, and then
they told her: we destroy
your home, we're gonna
take you somewhere tonight.
And she said: no, you have
to take me back to my home.
I'm gonna die in my home if I'm dying.
I will die with dignity.
So they brought her back to the home
and had home arrest for 10 days.
And what's unique, I think,
my mom is not sharing,
and it's amazing, like, as a family,
the whole country, we are
relieved they released her,
she's home, and we want
everything, the work,
to resume and everything.
Let's forget about what happened.
No, she insisted, she said:
no, I'm not starting anything
unless they apologize.
(laughing)
So it's like: what the hell?
Mom, I'm begging you, this is enough.
You know, you were about to get killed,
and we have a lot, everything destroyed,
and we have to rebuild
basically the hospital,
the structures and everything.
She says: no, no, they have
to write apology letter.
It's not even one, three of it.
(laughing)
One is for me, one is for the community,
and one for the MSF.
That time it was Doctors Without Boarders
who were running all pediatric
sections of the hospital,
and they took a week conversation
and back and forth and we are all like:
okay, another attack can happen tomorrow.
So we didn't know, but
finally we were surprised,
they wrote the letter.
- One letter or three?
- Three letters, and they brought to her.
It's like: Mama Hawa,
these are your letters.
Let's open the hospital, because--
(applauding)
- Amazing.
- It's, I really admire
her courage, I think.
It's the first time in
the history of Somalia
someone not only stood up to the warlords
and the Islamists, but
also taught them a lesson.
You need to apologize; what
you have done was wrong.
(laughing)
- So, since 2012-2013, much
more peace has come to Somalia.
I would love to hear what
the work has been like
since the peace has been more
able to stabilize the country
and make the work much less dangerous
than these years that
you're describing from 2010.
And I believe we have some
photos of some of the work.
- Yeah.
- I will share with you some
photos at the foundation.
That's a beautiful photo
of Glamour, in 2010,
when we received Glamour
Women of the Year.
The three of us, me and
my mom and my sister.
And it took two hours to take that shot.
(laughing)
After this photo, I have
deep respect for models.
I was thinking it was very
easy to take photos before.
Next, it's like: please!
So that's the hospital.
And this photo, I really,
it's one of my favorite photos
because it's super busy,
it's the outpatient,
you see the registration is going on,
the PB, they're checking
the weight, you know,
mothers are lining up.
This is the peak, when we had over 90,000.
And daily, we were receiving
500 and over patients.
Next slide.
So this is the medical
outreach mobile clinics
we do in the village; we still do.
We try to keep the, as
soon as we get some window
for safety in an area to go, we go out.
It's very beautiful,
it's very rewarding to go
and visit and just take
all your medicine with you.
There's nothing in there, and
then mothers are lining up,
waiting for you; next slide.
And this is the primary school.
The school is very dear
to me and favored to me.
It's education, I loved
it, and when my high school
and my country falls apart, so,
still to stick to my back,
so this school was opened
in 2000, and it has a different story,
where we opened and it didn't work,
we opened and it closed, but since 2008
and now nine years is the
school functioning fully.
This is the primary school.
Next slide, with my mom
in the middle of it,
we took this photo when
we distributed the shirts.
This is the pre-K, preschool.
These toys was delivered from
Washington DC and Seattle,
from Vital Voices, and
we're very grateful.
So I tried my best to have as
any preschool in the world,
so they can have the games
and education in early age,
and we prepare for them in the future.
Next slide.
This is one of my favorite
photos of the primary school.
Next slide.
And this photo was taken by New York Times
when they visited in our
primary school when it was full.
Over 27,000 kids were out of the school,
and we could only have in this school 800.
So very small numbers.
When we say 800, people
think: oh, that's a lot!
But compared to the kids out
of the school, it's crazy.
And what I wanna really
mention here today,
this photo was taken
three, four years ago,
but these kids are now in high school.
And they're taking this class
that Nicola and Charlotte
was talking on, Hope is Here,
and all this came together
because of Sarah Luloe,
and we, I want to teach,
and my mom always tells,
you know, the problem
in Somalia is people,
they don't know their rights.
And that's her law speaking,
and that's what I decided
to do and I'm really, yell
and yell for law school,
and the Schell Center helped
to put this program together.
And we have very big ambitions.
And we were in the beginning
thinking we might just
have one year, then every
year we keep adding,
and we keep improving.
Now we have a four-year program,
and we're hoping to take this
not only in our high school,
and all over Somalia and teach the kids
the conflict resolution,
how this could work.
Next slide.
This is the map of the
village, in Google Earth.
I just took it yesterday
night, so if you go look at it.
I just want people to
understand how, you know,
how massive it is and
how people are living in,
and why we call it a village
and not a camp anymore,
because people were there for 26 years,
and now we have more
concrete structures in place,
not only plastic sheets.
And just to dignify, you
know, how they mobilize,
how they organize themselves,
so this is all, ah,
let me see if I can point.
Is it gonna work or not?
Oh yes, that's the school.
That's the high school we just built.
And it has a huge playground,
so the kids can have fun.
So this is all small structures,
the hospital, and this
is the primary school.
Beginning, this is the
road, the main road.
So this is the first settlement.
And this is the football ground,
and this is the other settlement.
Each settlement we have
here, this is the back,
where we have mango trees, this is the,
my mom's, what she calls Camp David.
She gets rest and goes back there
after all the crazy work
that's going on in there.
So it's very massive,
and this part of the road
is our land, but we are also responsible
for six kilometers around us.
So the UN and international community,
when there's funding
and food distribution,
we cover all areas.
The next slide.
This is how we decide, actually.
We have the committee,
and there's no office.
There's no city hall you go.
It's everyone comes to the Camp
David under the mango trees.
So that's the mango trees.
And solving a case, and we had a visitor,
this young diaspora of boys and girls
came to visit and see how we could solve
the daily cases and
discussion between them.
So I wanted to take, we
took the photo; next slide.
And this is the daily new arrivals,
because the, you have a
clash, people will come.
The village and the camp is known
all over Somalia, so
they come for temporary,
when their village gets quiet,
they go back, their city.
So we do have every day,
every other day, new arrivals,
or every other week,
maybe two, three families.
The minute they arrive, we try to register
and give whatever food we
have, or plastic sheets,
and find places to stay.
If they have already a
relative in the village,
they will stay with their relatives.
Next slide.
And this is another new
arrival, just waiting outside.
Of the hospital, in front of the hospital.
This structure, and next slide.
And I wanted to just a little
bit talk about the drought.
So next it's the drought, and it's, ah,
it's really heartbreaking.
It's all, you wanna go forward.
We have a government system in place,
I have been here doing my wonderful Yale
(muttering) programs, six months,
and then as soon as I went
home, the drought starts.
The election, and I felt
like we'd gone backward
instead of forward, so
it was a very tough time
for me and it was very hard
to see the same drought
we have seen, even worse than 2011.
So 2011, the whole world supported.
Somalia was there, we did
fundraising and everything,
and after a short five years,
you're still in the same place
and there's no structure in anything.
So we gathered a lot of
young Somalis, come together,
we have all our frustration, we thought:
okay, let's use our
frustration for something good.
So let's not wait until
international community reached us,
which NGO's, everyone, we
(unintelligible) outside.
Let's do something inside.
And that worked, and so we
created a mobile system,
we started feeding, we started
putting every 10 kilometers
some feeding centers, we
gathered together information,
then a dilemma comes in; it's like:
we don't know who we're helping.
We don't know who is where, helping.
So, next slide.
Oh, this is the feeding center.
Now we have it in, and
this is for the children.
In the beginning, we
do the porridge, cook,
and all our, we took this
food from the local stores.
From the business guys.
So we didn't even wait until money comes.
We call everyone who
knows, and they ask for,
please send $100, $50, buying the food,
collecting the food, high school students
going out to the homes
and stores, asking food.
So that's what, how we mobilize.
Next slide.
Next slide; this is the
children in the morning,
breakfast, so, ah, it's gone, the rice.
- [Liu] It might come
back; they're trying.
- [Deqo] Okay, that's,
ah, so I wanted just
to go back to that mob; next slide.
Ah, this is the food for the
rice we cook for the adults.
Next slide.
And next.
This is the map; I just wanna talk, what,
it's the drought and
how we can reach people.
Where we are reaching,
where people are dying.
And as we know, when the drought comes,
there's not enough water,
and it's all preventable diseases comes.
So immediately, like, three
weeks when I was back in Somalia
the watery diarrhea broke
out, in our village.
Not too far, we have enough water,
but the next neighbors,
and we lost two kids.
Immediately, first couple of days.
And it's preventable.
It's very frustrating,
being in this situation.
So we created this unique map
with young Somali diaspora
in Sweden, in Holland, in London,
gathered it together
using technologies today,
given this information, and
then you see the red area
is the where we have a death.
Orange, it's food that's needed,
and then in green where we have NGO's.
We know someone is there.
And we need to call that
NGO, so we communicated
within one month, we put
the whole country map.
This united us; there's
no division in Somalia.
We didn't care; it's that
they all show up at an area,
or we had someone else, we had
to care if people were dying.
And young people united
and then gathered together
for only the situation in drought.
And something good came out,
but it's very frustrating
to me to be in that situation.
And also, it's very empowering;
we could do something.
We could make a difference,
before even anyone gets there
and before the international
community reached us.
And we reduced the numbers
of death for diarrhea,
we reduced the number
of death for starvation,
and this project is still going on.
We have the website now,
and Minister of Humanitarian Disaster
is working with us to put
information in our website.
Also the UN is following our website.
We put the report; it's
very easy, simple thing.
Everyone can go in and put
the information with the phone
and the four of us will
verify: is this true or not?
So we call everyone when we
have verified it's really true.
We will follow and we will
ask: who's the closest one
to distribute food or water
to them, or medicine, even?
So that's how we mobilize,
and it's amazing,
and then it's good too,
but we have to have more
sustainable programs in the country.
So that's, that's, ah, next slide?
I think I'm done.
So that's the future
generation of Somalia.
Future leaders, here, and
this is one of my favorite
photos in the village.
- Thank you so much, this is, I think,
a great place to end with thinking about
all the amazing work
that you've been doing
for the many decades, the
work that you're still doing,
and then the hope in Somalia's future.
So thank you for being here, today.
(applauding)
(murmuring)
So, we're gonna bring the
lights back up in the house,
and we will, if all of you have questions
that you want to pose to
Doctors Abdi and Mohamed,
we'd be very happy to have a few of them.
I think we have a little
bit of time for questions.
So I think everyone has,
should have a paper and pencil.
So if you can pass your questions,
there are aides coming
down the aisle to collect,
and if you do not have a paper and pencil,
just raise your hand and someone,
and one of the aides should get to you.
So, yeah.
Mariah, I think people raising their hand
if they want a paper or pencil, yeah.
Alright, thanks.
So we're gonna do questions
now, but thank you so much.
This is wonderful, yeah.
- I want to say to the audience,
thank you for coming and
sharing my history with me.
Yes, and I want to thank--
(applauding)
I want to thank also Yale University
for giving me this opportunity to see,
to see this beautiful college.
Thank you very much.
- Thank you for coming.
(speaking foreign language)
- Okay, Mariah, maybe we
should just bring some down.
Because we can always keep collecting.
Thanks so much; okay, alright.
Okay, you ready for the first question?
Okay, what has your experience taught you
about the role of
humanitarian aid from foreign
organizations and their
relationship with local NGO's?
(laughing)
Not an easy question.
- No, it's a tough question.
(speaking foreign language)
Oh. (laughing)
It's, humanitarian aid is
excellent in a disaster,
just to deliver one time,
but when it comes alive
for almost a quarter of a
century, it's a disaster.
It's basically disaster.
You're creating a whole
generation dependent on aid.
The whole system of aid is
not set up for sustainability
and for the future, so
it's all the same cycle.
You fundraise, you finish the money,
you come back, the project ends,
and billions of money was
wasted for the last 20 years
in Somalia, 25 years.
And nothing is done, so
it's very painful to me.
It's good to have humanitarian work,
but we have to restructure, and we think
in a more sustainable
way, and maybe use only
what it needs for that
emergency; it's not continuously.
It's not effective.
- But it saves lives.
- Yes.
- It saves lives.
- So it's a double-edged
sword, yeah, in that way.
This second question,
oh, thank you so much.
This,
so I apologize ahead of time,
because there's quite a few questions,
and we'll do our best to
get through as many of them
as we can, but the second question is:
given your experience, you
have both been called on
to join multiple peace
conferences and committees
that aim to chart a peaceful
and politically sustainable
future for Somalia.
What has your experience
been like with these,
and what can we take
away from these projects,
given that many have failed in the past?
(speaking foreign language)
- I have no--
I know, I want to tell you
that everything you want,
you can reach.
Just it needs to be
persistent and committed.
And nothing is impossible, this world.
Although this world now is spiraling.
Our world is burning, now.
Greedy, terrorists, pain,
and the world is ours, the world is one.
Human being is one.
Our needs is one.
Every one of us has a
responsibility to make this world
peaceful place, because
we want to live nicely.
And that's dependent on us.
If people, human beings know this is one,
their needs, this is
one, the world is one.
We are all one.
- Yeah, and what'd we learn from being in,
the question was, hm--
- The question?
- You captured, I think, some part of it.
- I hope so.
- Yes, you did, definitely did.
I have a question that is,
in some ways, a follow-up.
It says: in the face of
tribalism, war and famine,
how have you found the
strength to live and love
through it all, I think?
What should you, ah,
what would you want Somalis and
everyone to know about love?
So, it's kind of a profound
question in some ways.
(speaking foreign language)
- God gives me that strength.
- God gave you the strength, yeah.
(murmuring)
- You need to speak louder.
- Okay, God gives me the strength.
- I think, to me, it's the
people that inspire me.
And I think my mom also
would say it's the people
of Somalia.
- The people respect me,
loves me, and I love them.
I love my country and my people.
I give already my life and soul
for my people and my country.
And they're spreading.
And I'm getting also
international respect,
to other human beings,
of this five continents.
- Yes, you most definitely
have our deepest respect.
Oh dear, it will be okay.
We have a question here that
wants to have more details
about the storage closet.
(laughing)
Is there anything more
to add to that story?
- Nothing much really.
It's just a way to punishing
the mistake has done.
So if you let it go, what happens?
And you say: talk about it.
And it's not gonna be solved.
But when you punish it in a soft way,
because you have still a
conflict zone, you have trauma,
you cannot just do as a
real jail or anything,
or have strong rules and law.
I think it helped a lot and it's basic,
some days it's full; we don't
have space to arrest anyone.
And some days the food distribution time,
we don't arrest anyone.
We try to find other rooms to close.
That's the way it works;
nothing special or fancy.
Or you don't have a specific
jail funding for that.
(laughing)
- Right.
So this question is: what
was the most difficult
disagreement or conflict that
arose in Hawa Abdi Village?
That you needed to resolve?
It might be difficult to
pick one, but you can try.
(speaking foreign language)
- To stop clan division.
- Clan division?
- Clan division.
That was very difficult,
for all Africa and all,
for Somalia, but I,
I win in my village;
there is no clan division.
But all other country in Africa,
they have clan division, even Somali more.
- It's, what I think we always
have the conversation is,
the problem in how we
are very linked and tied
and dependent on clan
because it's insurance.
Basically, when you have a
sick child or there's a death,
your clan funds you.
So that's why people are
dependent on clan issues.
So I think the biggest issue she solved
is to release this dependency to the clan.
So when people have the opportunity,
the hospital where they
can bring their kids
when they're sick, you know, the community
that supports them when they need things,
I think the biggest problem
she solved, she's not saying,
is just making, teaching
people you don't have to be,
belong to clan allegiance
and agree with them,
wrong and right; you can
be independent and have,
as a human being, and
support your fellow humans.
I think that was the
biggest challenge I think
she solved in the camp.
But the daily cases, one by
one, it happens, you know?
It's a war zone.
Today you have a gun pointed on you,
and her kidnap situation to
me was the most hard part.
- So, I think I'm gonna conclude by,
there are two quick comments.
I believe we might have
some Somalis in the audience
who wanna express their
thanks to you for all
the amazing work that you've done.
So I just wanna make
sure to acknowledge that,
that voice of gratitude.
And then the last question is:
how can we best support your work?
- Oh, fantastic.
(laughing)
In many, many ways.
You can join the wonderful Two Program,
this is going on in Yale, at
the business class in Jackson,
supporting the ideas, and one of the,
really what I needed, my doing here,
and we talk a lot with
my mom and my sister,
how we could be sustainable.
How we could be independent,
how we could create more jobs.
That brings the peace and
stability in the country.
And we have a great opportunity here,
at Jackson Institute, to
do, are helping us to create
a business in a failed state,
which is one of its kind
in the world, I think
so, and we're trying.
So you can get involved physically,
or it might be the school,
for the education program,
or the best thing is to give
money, go to the website.
So this is one thing I've learned.
You cannot do anything without money.
That's how we're creating the business.
We have to be very honest to ourselves.
The majority why these states are failing
is because there's no funding;
the government is weak
and corrupted and people
don't have their money.
So when you don't have a job,
you will not be able to do anything.
- Thank you so much, and of course,
we will let you have the last words.
So whatever last, parting comments,
you have all the audience,
please feel free to share them.
(speaking foreign language)
- I tell all human beings they are one.
And they will have to defend each other.
We have to defend each other.
We have to try to live a
peaceful and good life,
and that is, we can do, we can do that.
If we know reality, that
we are one, everywhere.
When something happens in
one corner of this world,
the other corner will split and reach.
So we have to stop every bad
thing and help each other.
I want to say that people
have to support each other,
have to prevent every
bad thing in this world,
and make this world a
better place for living.
For us, for our children,
for our grandchildren.
- Thank you so much.
- Thank you.
(applauding)
(musical theme)